what's the first step in writing a
screenplay oh wow
having the idea and knowing how to
develop it
sometimes people will come to me and
they i've got a great idea
and i said well write it down oh no i
just want to tell
this i just want to pitch it to somebody
and have them write it into a movie and
get paid for the idea and i said
hate to tell you but they don't pay
money for ideas but once you have
something written down
like a synopsis of your story where you
have it
well you have most of the major details
lined out all you have to do is register
it with the writer's guild
if it's a screenplay if it's a novel
i think you know you need to you may
want to register with copyright people
or
or somebody like that you know just so
that you have a record of of having um
uh written it but you know you have to
write it down you can't just expect
somebody
if you just tell them the story you
can't expect them to just say okay yes
here's
here's some money and i'd like to buy it
what do you think stops people from
writing it down
i've heard that too oh i have so many
ideas they're up here they're here
you know what when you write something
down on paper
well first of all or what it is nowadays
is when you type it into your computer
it's there it's and it's hard
it's it's um and then it's sometimes
painful to read it because you're not
quite sure
you know you have it down in your head
but is it going to translate well when
you read it
and it's almost two different things
because you have seen things visually
and you're trying to put all of it in
there so what's tough for writers i
think is sometimes
when writers do a whole script or a
whole novel or a whole manuscript
it's hard for them to try and focus when
they have to edit it
that's the hard hard process sometimes
they can get everything all written down
but then they don't understand that you
can't write everything down and expect
everybody to accept all of it you have
to pare it down so the story is
much clearer it's more easy to
understand
and also that do you have sympathetic
characters do you have dialogue that
rings
true is there a message or a theme
that shines through and so all of those
things kind of come into play
you